Wir wollen jetzt sprechen über La Liga, die Premier League, die Serie A und die Liga. Das tun wir mit Christian Bernhardt, Alexi Menüch, Fabian Pakulat und später noch zugeschaltet Uli Hebel und los geht's! Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr eingeschaltet habt und schön, dass ich hier meine kompetente Runde begrüßen darf. Wir springen gleich rein in die Themen. Keine Zeit zu verlieren. Alexi, wenn du magst, dann leg du doch sehr gerne mal los. Du wirst uns erklären, warum es bei Olympique Marseille schon wieder nicht läuft. Und ich habe gehört, dass de Zerbi schon so wütend verzweifelt war, dass er sein angebliches Papier, was er von Manchester United bekommen hätte, an die Kabinenwand geworfen hat, um den Spielern zu sagen, da hätte ich sein können, ich bin bei euch, jetzt läuft meine Freunde und gewinnt endlich mal. Stimmt das denn, was ich da gehört habe?
Also wir legen das ab unter das Glück, Investoren zu haben in seiner Liga und wir legen es ab. Ich meine, Claudio Ranieri mit 73 Jahren, also US-Präsident könnte er noch werden. Wer weiß, wie lange er…
Ich finde, dass du das Alter sagst. Genau, ich wollte dich auch noch ansprechen.
Ja, und wer weiß, vielleicht, also mich wundert es eigentlich, dass in dem Moment, in dem Iban Juric entlassen wurde, nicht Mats Hummels ein Video gepostet hat, wie er durch seinen Pferdestall joggt. Oder vielleicht habe ich da jetzt gerade was durcheinander geworfen. Aber vielleicht findet der ja auch wieder sein Plätzchen bei der Roma und das vielleicht ja sogar länger auf dem Feld, als es bisher zu sehen war. Ihr drei, das hat große Freude gemacht. Danke euch herzlich und wir machen an dieser Stelle jetzt dann noch einmal kurz weiter mit der Premier League. Uli Hebel ist jetzt hier und spricht mit mir über die Premier League. Uli, schön, dass du da bist.
Finde ich auch. Schönen guten Abend, grüß dich.
Ja, damit haben wir auch geleakt, dass ein halber Tag zwischen der Vormittagsaufnahme und jetzt liegt. Aber für dich ist es völlig egal. Den Hörern und Hörern ist das egal. Wir wollen sprechen über die Premier League. Und da wollen wir jetzt mal blicken auf Brighton. Denn das werden die Hörerinnen und Hörer mitbekommen haben. Die stehen nicht nur fantastisch in der Tabelle da. Punktgleich mit Nottingham, Arsenal und Chelsea. Das ist quasi Platz 3, 4 und 5. Und Brighton dann eben auf 6 mit 19 Punkten. Sondern auch einen echten Überraschungssieg gelandet gegen City.
Ja, also Brighton erscheint auch nicht erweitert schon früh in der Saison. Also nicht erst jetzt im November oder auch im Oktober, sondern eigentlich mehr oder weniger von Spieltag 1 an hoch unterhaltsam. Damit habe ich einigermaßen gerechnet, dass es dem so sein könnte. Sie könnten hier und da etwas effizienter sein. Also Hürzeler selbst spricht da sehr deutlich davon, dass es naiv ist. Aber ich finde, in den allermeisten Spielphasen eigentlich wie ein richtiges Top-Team aufgestellt. Also spielen von hinten raus, haben wirklich einen sehr soliden Ballaufbau, sehr, sehr passsicher auch schon. Und das, obwohl im Übrigen ein paar fehlen, also es ist bei weitem noch nicht– sind alle gesund. Bloß die Mannschaft ist im Sommer sehr, sehr neu zusammengestellt worden. Also zum einen, weil de Zerbi gegangen ist, logisch, auf der anderen Seite, weil wie immer bei Brighton der ein oder andere gegangen ist und in dem Fall aber sogar, weil die Gewinne reinklicken, die sie gemacht haben in den letzten Jahren. Transfererlöse und so weiter und so weiter. Und aufgrund der– fällt das nochmal stärker ins Gewicht– aufgrund der Problematik, was PSA betrifft, also Nachhaltigkeitsregeln, die andere Vereine mitbringen, fällt es nochmal deutlich ins Gewicht, dass Brighton schon sehr, sehr viel Geld ausgegeben hat, vor allen Dingen offensiv Geld ausgegeben hat. Deswegen eigentlich alle damit gerechnet haben. Da kommt ein junger Trainer, der noch nie auf dem Niveau gecoacht hat, der noch nie natürlich in dem Land gecoacht hat, sogar in der Liga, in der es, sagt man immer, sehr kompliziert ist. Und dann noch mit neuen Spielern. Und dafür sieht es, finde ich, schon sehr, sehr flüssig aus, was passiert. Also sowohl am Ball als auch zum Teil gegen den Ball. Es gibt halt dann– und das ist aber dann vielleicht auch dem Alter geschuldet– schon immer mal so Phasen von 10 Minuten, wo sie dann wegknicken, dann wirklich auch teilweise Spiele nicht gewinnen, die sie eigentlich klar gewissen. Wolfs ist wahrscheinlich so ein Beispiel, das müsste gewesen sein Ende Oktober. Da laufen sie 4 gegen 1 auf einen Wolf zu und spielen den Ball tatsächlich in die Füße und kassieren halt dann den Ausgleich. Und da der sich halt maßlos drüber geärgert, Fabian nutzt auch zurecht auch, finde ich auch im Übrigen sehr cool, dass der dann nicht irgendwie einen Hehl daraus macht, dass er da enttäuscht ist und gar nicht in Schutz die Truppe nimmt, sondern im Gegenteil sagt er, ne, sorry, so können wir das nicht machen. Und das muss man gewinnen und fertig. Und das macht er im Übrigen in jedem Spiel. Und deswegen sind die schon zu nennen als die wahrscheinlich, also Nottingham, kommen wir dann vielleicht auch noch drauf, aber wahrscheinlich die größte Überraschung der Liga mit Nottingham zusammen.
Aber diese Ehrlichkeit, die du da angesprochen hast, und dass auch die Mannschaft dann in die Pflicht nehmen, kann das nicht auch backfiern, wie man auf Englisch sagt? Also, sich kontraproduktiv auswirken, wenn er das schon so früh macht in der Saison?
Ja, dessen ist er sich auch bewusst. Wer weiß schon, dass das Formulieren von Ambitionen, das ist jetzt ein sinngemäßes Zitat auch, das er ihm am Telefon gegeben hat, das Formulieren von Ambitionen kann natürlich auch als leichte Arroganz ausgelegt werden. Im Speziellen, wenn er es so vorträgt, wie er es vorträgt. Und im Moment, du weißt ja selber, manchmal ist es im Sportjournalismus auch um Narrative. Im Moment ist es Narrative in England, das ist das FAB, so nennen sie ihn schon, der junge Trainer, der dahin kommt, kein Respekt hat und dann sogar Guardiola weghaut, eine seiner Idole. Deswegen lässt man die andere Geschichte jetzt mal weg. Wenn es aber mal nicht so gut laufen würde, bin ich mir schon ziemlich sicher, und ich glaube, das weiß er auch, dann kommt es auch. Aber, und das ist das Gute an ihm, er ist sich dessen total bewusst. Also der geht da jetzt nicht blind rein und sagt, ja gut, jetzt findet er mich cool und später mögt er mich nicht so gerne, sondern ihm ist völlig klar, dass das ein Problem werden wird, so wie er sich aber nur mal ausdrücken möchte. Das ist das, das finde ich auch das Schöne. Das sage ich jetzt, das sagt nicht er, aber das ist für mich immer eine Metapher. Also ich will jetzt kein Name-Jopping betreiben oder so, aber es gibt ja zwei, drei deutschsprachige Trainer und in dem Fall lässt er sich darauf ein, dass ich ihn trotzdem anrufen darf, wenn ich ein Brighton-Spiel habe. Und er hat auch gesagt, es ist in Ordnung, das zu sagen. Und da habe ich mal mit ihm darüber geredet und nach dem Wolfs-Spiel, das ich kommentiert hatte, vor dem Liverpool-Spiel dann gesagt, ich will jetzt nicht irgendwie respektlos klingen oder so, aber wenn man jetzt das Ganze böse formulieren würde, dann wäre das naiv. Dann sagt er, ja, formulieren wir es doch böse, also ist es doch. Und das ist das, dann habe ich nur gesagt, oh, okay, dann sagt er, naja, nur wenn man jung ist, kann man trotzdem reif auftreten. Und das ist dann meine Anschätzung des Ganzen, das ist eine Metapher, die natürlich eine Doppelsinnigkeit hat. Weil ihn nervt das immer, glaube ich, mit dem Alter auf eine Weise, weil er sagt, nehmt mich bitte ernst als Fußballtrainer, was ich völlig verstehen kann, weil ich trainiere in der Premier League. Und ich werde, also du kriegst ja keinen extra Punkt, nur weil du 31 bist, was immer noch schon echt erstaunlich ist. Und ich glaube, das möchte er nicht. Er möchte diesen Schutz nicht, sondern er möchte als Fußballtrainer bewertet werden. Und er will ihn aber seinen Spielern auch nicht geben. Und das finde ich konsequent. Und ich glaube, das sind die Dinge, wo du als Fußballspieler wahrscheinlich sagst, hm, genau, der Trainer, der hat keine Doppelmoral, der fordert nicht für sich etwas ein, das er uns nicht gibt, sondern er macht so, wie es sich gehört. Ich glaube, das ist das, was hilft, wenn ich so die Truppe einschätze, gerade bei jungen Spielern. Es ist, glaube ich, extrem wichtig, dass der Trainer lebt, was er sagt.
Also auf den Kader und wer da die entscheidenden Spieler sind, müssen wir gleich noch mal kommen. Aber eine letzte Frage noch zu Hürzeler. Also es war natürlich ein großes Thema, dass er der erste Trainer ist, der jünger ist als die Liga, in der er trainiert mit seinen 31 Jahren. Ich weiß, dass viele englische Journalisten sich üben durften am Ort Pippinsried, der uns als Münchner natürlich leicht von den Lippen geht. Das ist ein bisschen schwieriger für die. Aber wie kommt er denn in der Medienöffentlichkeit an? Denn gerade als zum Beispiel Jürgen Klopp damals gewechselt ist in die Premier League, war das ja ein großes Thema. Wie würde er mit der Yellow Press und so weiter umgehen?
Also, wenn auch David das Narrativ sagt, das deutschsprachige Trainer, ich nehme jetzt mal Glas damit rein, wenn wir die Rückrunde bei Crystal Palace zählen, aber auch Hasenüttel zum Beispiel, Southampton, die haben schon gecheckt, dass es eine Fußballrichtung, also für die Engländer ist alles, was aus Deutschland kommt, Gegenpressing. Mehr gibt es nicht. Und das ist eine Fußballrichtung, die funktioniert. A, die B kopiert wird und die C von Deutschen gelehrt wird und deshalb war schon klar, die haben schon sehr, sehr viel Respekt gehabt, als er kam. Ich fand natürlich diesen Fakt des Wunderkids schon auch lustig, aber insgesamt mag man den medial sehr, weil– und das ist ja in England– gibt es ja keine Interviews links und rechts, gibt es ja überhaupt nicht. Also kein Journalist. Also geschweige denn die Kollegen aus England, mit denen ich korrespondiere, die fassen sich an den Schädel, wenn sie sagen, wieso telefonierst du mit dem Trainer? Und dann sag ich, was ist das los? Und dann sag ich, ist das irgendwie bei uns in Deutschland? Ist das so? Dass man halt irgendwie versucht, zumindest so vorm Spiel was zu machen. Und es gibt aber auch gar kein Print-Interview oder sowas. Weil die Print-Journalisten überhaupt gar nicht danach fragen. Das heißt, du siehst und triffst den bei Pressekonferenzen. Und ab und an mal, wenn der Beatwriter halt in der Mixed Zone stehen bleibt und der Trainer, wenn ihm langweilig ist, machen aber meistens die Co-Trainer. Und auch da versucht er halt einfach, kein riesiges Geheimnis aus der Sache zu machen. Das ist wahrscheinlich das Beste, was man über ihn sagen kann. Du fragst ihn was, er gibt dir eine Antwort. So gut er kann. Und das Gefühl habe ich und das Gefühl haben auch alle englischen Kollegen, dass er wirklich sagt, okay, wenn du es wissen willst, klar, erklär es dir. So gut ich halt kann.
Also sind wir mal gespannt, wie sich das alles weiterentwickeln wird. Es ist ja noch sehr früh in seiner Station jetzt bei Brighton. Jetzt hast du ja schon angesprochen, man hat auch sehr, sehr viel investiert, also über 200 Millionen Euro in neue Spieler gesteckt in diesem Sommer. Sind es denn auch die Neuzugänge, die diese Saison wesentlich prägen? Oder wer sind so die wichtigen Spieler?
Noch nicht so die Neuzugänge, würde ich sagen, weil bei Brighton, das ist aber, hat Methode, die transferieren eigentlich immer so, dass sie die Abgänge schon mal zwei Transferfenster im Voraus versuchen zu ersetzen. Das heißt, die kommen dann sozusagen nach einem Jahr oder vielleicht sogar eineinhalb Jahren erst so richtig in die Mannschaft rein, dürfen derweil mal heranschmecken. Das soll sich ändern. Brian Goddard zum Beispiel, der da ist, der soll, glaube ich schon, sehr, sehr schnell auch Richtung Stammmannschaft geführt werden. Wäre eine kleinere Ausnahme. Und Ruitier spielt sehr viel jetzt. Dessen Zahlen sind noch so la la, aber auch das weiß man bei Brighton oder wusste man. Der Besitzer, Tony Blum, ist ein Profi Pokerspieler. Und der ist ein sehr, sehr zahlenorientierter Fußballkonsument geworden. Also der ist einfach mal reingekommen als Fußballfan und hat sich das Ganze dann aber, weil er sehr zahlentalentiert ist, einfach mal alles zeigen lassen, sagen lassen. Und der muss irgendeinen Algorithmus entwickelt haben, der bei Ruitier geblinkt hat, sodass fast das Ding explodiert wäre, auf dem er den Algorithmus wahrscheinlich abgelesen hat. Und ich kann dir nicht genau sagen, welche Werte das sind. Darüber schweigt die gesamte Fußballwelt. Aber das war bei Hofmeister und so. Und es war auch bei Lidz so, dass genau das Gleiche passiert ist. Also ich vermute, das ist irgendwo im Bereich der Expected Assists, weil ich kann es mir nicht bei Expected Goals so richtig vorstellen. Der Abschluss ist Solala. Von dem irgendwie generell die Entscheidungsfindung ist Solala. Der ist sprachlich kommunikativ auch nicht so besonders. Das hat man mir auch in Hofmeyerm schon gesagt. Aber theoretisch ist das so ein 1 gegen 1 Monster, der so ganz clever die Zwischenräume besetzt. Und ich glaube, da könnte was gehen, wenn man denen sozusagen den Ball gibt, im Zwischenraum der dreht auf, läuft mit Tempo auf die Kette zu und würde dann das richtige Abspiel finden. Dann könnte der sehr gefährlich sein. Ich deute da immer mal an, dass der schwierig zu halten sein müsste, kommt aber kaum was rum. Und auch von den anderen, wenn ich mir das so überlege, eigentlich kein richtiger Neuzugang, der jetzt so eine totale Rolle spielt. Ich glaube, Matt O'Reilly, der jetzt am Wochenende gegen City dann das Tor geschossen hat, auch das Entscheidende. Das soll einer sein. Der war bis dato verletzt. Das soll derjenige sein, der sowohl die Standardsituation tritt, in Absenze von Groß und vor allen Dingen auch einfach Torgefahr aus dem Mittelfeld. Das haben sie nämlich so gar nicht. Ich glaube, der könnte eine Rolle spielen. Brian Guder ebenfalls, der auf dem rechten Flügel eingeplant ist. Aber ansonsten sind es eigentlich Mats Viva auch, der soll auch. Der ist aber viel verletzt. Danny Welbeck ist wahrscheinlich in dieser Saison, wenn ich einen nennen müsste, der, der den Unterschied am Ersten macht, liegt daran, dass er gesund ist. Das ist bei ihm zu allererst mal zu nennen. Weil ich glaube, wir würden völlig anders über Danny Welbeck sprechen, wenn er nicht dauernd verletzt gewesen wäre im Verlauf seiner Karriere. Das habe ich mir nur sagen lassen, er ist ein extremer Profi, hat einen eigenen Physiotherapeut, mit dem er wahnsinnig viel arbeitet, super fleißig, guckt viel, lässt sich viel sagen, will aber auch was haben von sich aus. Er ist immer so einer, der ist so leicht, im Englisch sagt man slick, also so gerissener Hund manchmal. Der lässt sich mal fallen, wo du denkst, was machst du da? Und dann zwei Sekunden später denkst du, ja, du öffnest den Raum damit, los geht's. Ich habe mir die Zahlen mal, das ist jetzt schon wieder eine Woche her, herausgeschrieben. Was seinen Abschlusspunkt angeht, ist er immer näher herangekommen im Verlauf seiner Karriere und ist jetzt da endlich mal komplett und nur auf der Neuen spielt, gar nicht mehr irgendwie Hengen-Spitze oder so etwas spielt, kommt immer näher ran bei seinen Abschlüssen. Entsprechend ist auch die Abschlussqualität gestiegen und aber auch die Verwertung gestiegen, weil er halt nur noch schießt oder abschließt, wenn er wirklich in einer aussichtsreicheren Position ist. Früher hat er manchmal geballert, kam einfach so von links rausgedriftet und hat einfach nur aus zweiter Reihe drauf geballert oder einfach mal irgendetwas genommen. Völlig wild und der wird immer cleverer. Ich glaube auch haushaltender, das zählt auch dazu, dass er sich das ein oder andere spart an Aktionen. Und deshalb in der Saison war wahrscheinlich der Main-Man, den Mitoma immer auch noch zu nennen, über den Flügel, weil der im 1 gegen 1, das ist eine Gravitation, die da ausstrahlt, den kannst du nicht alleine lassen, weil sonst spielt er dich einfach aus und dann hast du ein Problem, auch noch nicht so ganz effizient. Ich glaube, da geht noch was in dem Punkt. Aber von den Offensiven sind es die zwei in der Defensive, was wir wahrscheinlich Van Hecke nennen. Erstens, weil er von den Innenverteidigern der Einzige ist, der im Moment fit ist, permanent fit ist. Und zweitens, weil der gerade riesengroße Schritte macht, fußballerisch sowieso, richtig gut. Er kann undribbeln, ist ein sehr, sehr progressiver Verteidiger, sowohl im Dribbling als auch im Passen geworden. Das ist auch so einer. Der war da so eineinhalb Jahre im Kader und alle dachten so, ja, Van Hecke, was weiß ich. Und irgendwann, vor einem Jahr, so um die Zeit, kam er plötzlich und du denkst dir, oh, krass, ist Instant einer der besten jungen Innenverteidiger und hat jetzt inzwischen Level, dass der der Nächste ist, der für 60, 70 weggehen könnte, wenn sie loswerden wollen oder müssen irgendwann.
Ja, krasse Entwicklung bei Brighton. Und ich glaube, da müsste man auch nochmal im Detail mal draufgucken, was Danny Bloom da anders macht als vielleicht andere. Aber vorerst reicht das ja erst mal, um zu verstehen, warum Brighton so gut in die Saison gestartet ist und was eben auch die Talking Points sind. Neben The Fab, Fabian Hürzeler, der da quasi der Captain auf diesem Schiff ist, hast du uns noch jemand mitgebracht. Wir wollen noch ein paar kürzere Personalien und Geschichten abhandeln. Du hast für mich denjenigen mitgebracht, der bei Chelsea die Fäden in der Hand hält, den Überblick behält. Wie kann man es überhaupt formulieren? Wir wollen über Enzo Baresca sprechen.
Ganz so sicher bin ich mir auch noch nicht. Wer, wie, wo, was. Am Anfang der Saison habe ich immer gesagt, wir wissen ja leider viel zu viel von den ganzen Dingen, die da bei Clear Lake Capital zu stattfinden. Bei Maurizio Pochettino war es immer so, dass man gemerkt hat, dass er nicht hinter dem steht, was Clear Lake Capital ihm vorgibt, zu was er zu stehen hat. Und Enzo Baresca zu Beginn der Saison genau das gesagt, was die von ihm wollten. So hatte ich das Gefühl. Da tut man fast noch ein bisschen unrecht, weil man sagt, das ist deren Marionette, der macht das halt mal. Und sie wollten halt ein, zwei Spieler loswerden, wie zum Beispiel Remi Stirling, Ben Chilwell, alles Spieler. Das ist die Idee von Clear Lake Capital. Niemand, den wir nicht geholt haben, soll in diesem Verein sein. Weg. Sowohl im Staff als auch in der Mannschaft. Weg. Kostet es, was es wolle. Wirklich egal. Also kein Rücksicht auf das persönliche Schicksal eines Maseurs. Weg. Du bist kein Clear Lake Capital-Macher.
Es geht auch um den Staff, nicht nur ums Spiel. Ja, ja.
Alles. In diesem Verein hat niemand zu arbeiten, der nicht von Clear Lake Capital verpflichtet wurde.
Alter.
Immerhin konsequent und auch nach außen nicht so, aber nach innen wohl sehr, sehr deutlich kommuniziert. Zum Teil zu deutlich, so dass natürlich, kannst du dir vorstellen, das sind teilweise Legenden, Kid-Man und sowas. Naja.
Sieht ja wie die Busfahrer auf Schalke damals.
Genau. Ganz genau. Ja, das ist einfach der Verein. Da sind mir die Jesse-Fans immer so böse, wenn ich das sage. Aber der Verein, der jetzt geworden ist und der Clilic Capital, hat nichts mehr mit dem zu tun unter Braumowitsch. Und schon gar nicht mit dem, was vorher war. Gar nicht. Also überhaupt gar nicht. Das ist noch dasselbe Logo. That's it. Ansonsten nichts mehr. Ich finde es bewundernswert, wie Fans da dabei bleiben können, weil das wäre so der Moment, wo ich sagen würde, ja sorry, aber nur, weil es halt…
Ja gut, wahrscheinlich hilft halt Platz 3 mit 19 Punkten.
Ja, aber gut, genau. Da kommen wir dann ja zu dem positiven Punkt bei Enzo Maresca. Also die wollten die alle loswerden. Maresca hat gesagt, ja okay, wenn ihr denn loswerden wollt, ich sag nach außen, ich will ihn nicht, tschüss. Und der hat sich einfach aus diesem riesengroßen Kader, der es ja im Sommer gewesen ist, von theoretisch vier Mannschaftsbussen, dann gibt es natürlich eine Lone Army, der fährt schon mal ein Bus irgendwo hin, und dann hast du nur noch drei Busse und irgendwann waren es dann nur noch zwei, hat er einfach gesagt, okay, das sind meine vier bis 26 Jungs, mehr nicht, der Rest interessiert mich nicht, brauche ich nicht. Und das hat schon mal fürs Erste dafür gesorgt, dass, glaube ich, die Mannschaft gemerkt hat, oh, da ist Zug dahinter. Dann ein paar stringente Spiele, die da drin sind, das ist hoch unterhaltsam, was Chelsea tut, aber es ist in allererster Linie aufs Umschalten ausgelegt. Das heißt, sie spielen jetzt nicht den wunderschönsten Ball, was vielleicht auch mit Blick auf Leicester, was er da gemacht hat, gar nicht so schlecht ist, sich das so anzugucken. Und es hat sich einfach eine erste Mannschaft draus kristallisiert. Er hat einzelne Spieler, die Schwierigkeiten hatten, eine Zeit lang unter Pochettino, zum Schluss muss man fairerweise sagen, auch besser reingekommen sind. Also die Rückrunde war schon ganz ordentlich, hat sich die Qualität dann schon auch gezeigt, aber mit diesen verschiedenen individuellen Formen jeweils noch mal was angestellt, in die richtige Richtung gegossen, hat sich eine Stammmannschaft draus manövriert, was auch schon mal ganz wichtig war, weil es halt ein ewiges Gewechsel war die ganze Zeit und das dann noch mit so einer riesengroßen Kabine, das ist alles einfach wahnsinnig schwierig. Und er ist weiterhin sehr, sehr straight in dem, was er tut und vorgibt, sowohl eben außerhalb, bei den Antworten, die er so gibt, als auch auf dem Platz. Und das führt dazu, dass Chelsea's Qualität halt einfach– das war uns immer klar, das war ja auch deshalb das Projekt, vor dem die Fußballwelt, glaube ich, große Angst hat, weil wenn es funktioniert, dann weißt du ja selber, wie es ist, dann gibt es die Copycats. Und deswegen hat die ganze Fußballwelt so Angst davor, dass das funktioniert. Es war aber auch klar, die Qualität ist so überbordend gut, da steckt natürlich so viel an stilistischen Absichten drin, dass irgendwann mal irgendwas funktionieren müsste. Das sehen wir jetzt gerade. Und man muss aber insofern mal respektlos lassen, bis dato ist das nicht Elite. Soweit würde ich nicht gehen. Da fehlen mir schon noch ein paar Ansätze, dann auch gegen tiefere Gegner und so weiter. Aber sie haben insbesondere auch gegen Top-Teams gezeigt, da ist was da. Und auch mehr als nur ein formstarker Cole Palmer, der Darling von allen im Moment. Zu Recht auch, der spielt sensationell, das ist einfach ein wahnsinnig unterhaltsamer Spieler. Super Flair. Aber es ist schon mehr als das. Da steckt schon viel mehr drin. Das muss man Jersey lassen. Da haben sie einen Riesenschritt im Vergleich zu den letzten beiden Jahren gemacht, aber insbesondere auch noch mal zur letzten Saison. Deshalb Enzo Maresca, glaube ich, wäre fairerweise ein richtiger MVP, also wirklich valuable für Jersey.
Und wenn wir bei Menschen sind, die gegen Top-Teams da sind, dann können wir auch sehr gut zu Alexander Isak überleiten von Newcastle, denn der war unter anderem im Heimspiel gegen Arsenal da. 1 zu 0 Sieg. Er hat das Tor erzielt. Er war dann auch beim Auspelssieg bei Nottingham Forest da. 3 zu 1. Auch dort ein Tor, eine Vorlage. Der hat gerade eine sehr gute Phase.
Ja, ich sag es irgendwie, finde ich so ein neues Profil, das es gibt. Eigentlich ein Winger, so was die, was so die, die, also Lang, Dürr, aber ist nie ein Neuner geworden, sondern hat so was Wingerisches. So wie Ikke Tikee finde ich auch. So habe ich das auch in einem Bundesligaspiel mal gesagt. Ist auch so einer Leao irgendwie auf eine Weise. Das sind so Typen, die, wenn du die anschaust, würdest du denken, sie machen andere Dinge, als sie letztlich tun. Aber sie sind irgendwie immer ein bisschen drahtig geblieben und deswegen so schwer zu verteidigen. Und bei Isaac ist es auch so ähnlich wie, wie bei, bei so vielen, in Dortmund hat man ja schon gesehen, worum es gehen könnte. Dann bei der Altsocietat erst recht, aber nie gesund geblieben. Das war immer das große Problem bei dem. Auch bei Newcastle am Anfang, nie gesund geblieben. Trotzdem, je länger er dabei war, je länger er gesund war, desto besser ist er geblieben sozusagen. Und inzwischen ist das eigentlich alles, was du willst. Ist ein, der hat eine dermaßen starke Technik, kannst du dir gar nicht vorstellen. Der hat Läufe abseits des Balles, die natürlich auch noch durch die Athletik verstärkt werden. Super clevere Bewegungen. Läuft ständig in die Tiefe, kann aber genauso gut mit Ball am Fuß richtig eintribbeln, also richtig öffnen sozusagen. Hat für einen Stürmer eine wahnsinnig gute Balance. Ist de facto beidfüßig, wenn du so willst. Also ein bisschen schwierig, das sagen auch immer alle Scouts, das gibt es nicht. Und ich weiß auch, was sie meinen, so richtig gibt es das natürlich nicht. Aber wenn ich es dir jetzt vorher nicht sagen würde, dann würdest du wahrscheinlich draufkommen und sagen, der hat eigentlich einen relativ sauberen Schuss und eine relativ saubere Technik mit beiden Füßen. Ein guter Tripler und so etwas wie so ein Ein-Mann-Offensive, der eigentlich permanent Newcastle selber mal mit irgendwas, also sowohl wenn das Spiel mal steht, als auch im Transit, kann alles und wenn er gesund ist, Wahnsinn.
Unglaublich, wie der sich entwickelt hat. Ich meine, man hat es ja schon bei Réa Sociedad gesehen und deswegen ist er ja auch für viel Geld in die Premier League gewechselt. Aber ja, eins von vielen Dortmunder Talenten, das sich dann später nochmal richtig entwickelt hat. Das wäre…
Und nie eine Chance da bekommen hat, wenn wir ganz ehrlich sind. Also oder zumindest wahrscheinlich zu einem Zeitpunkt, als es noch unfair war, den richtig zu bewerten, weil das war mir aber auch relativ früh klar.
Das ist ein Fehler.
Der Körper alleine, da steckt viel drin.
Ja, gut. Ich meine, er hatte natürlich immer diese Größe und eben gleichzeitig diese Schlagsigkeit. Deswegen hat man vielleicht auch zu sehr klassische Mittelstürmer-Dinge von ihm erwartet. Auf der anderen Seite, der BVB hat es ja schon versucht, so zu machen, wie man es dann eben mit einem solchen Talent tun sollte. Nämlich, du verleihst ihn erstmal und guckst, ob er sich entwickelt. Und dann schaust du drauf. Und vielleicht haben sie dann zu früh dann aus welchen Gründen auch immer entschieden, okay, wir verkaufen ihn.
Da kann man auch mit 17. Der ist ja immer noch super jung. Das darf man immer noch nicht vergessen.
Genau.
Eigentlich geht es erst los. Also schon. Aber Theo Wolkert, glaube ich, hat das gesagt. Ich hoffe, ich mixe es jetzt nicht. Ich glaube, BBC, dass das Our Generation's Thierry Oury ist, was dann schon auch viel sagt. Passt nicht so ganz von der Spielweise, finde ich. Ist sogar einen Ticken kompletter, so blöd, das klingen mag, als Oury. Aber das ist, glaube ich, halt einfach so, weil sich die Spielerprofile generell zu komplett entwickelt haben. Oury wäre heute, glaube ich, auch jemand anderes, als er damals gewesen ist. Aber ich weiß, dass man meint, jemand, der für Newcastle halt ganz oft das Spiel packt und zack.
Tja. Ja, gut. Und wenn jemand weiß, wie es ist, sich in jungen Jahren mit großen Erwartungen auseinanderzusetzen, dann ja die U-War-Court. Das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema. Und unser letztes Thema haben wir schon kurz gestreift, nämlich Nottingham Forest. Auch wenn man verloren hat, eben gegen Newcastle, steht man sehr, sehr gut da. Man ist eben auch bei den Teams mit dabei, die 19 Punkte haben und damit von Rang 3 bis Rang 6 liegen, so wie Brighton, über die wir schon gesprochen haben. Was macht denn da Nottingham Forest gerade richtig?
Also zuallererst, das klingt immer so blöd, weil ja klar, aber sie haben eine klare Identität. Das hatten sie nie, seitdem sie zurück sind in der Premier League. Und wenn dann, unter Steve Cooper, dann war es halt Defensive First, aber das war es dann auch. Also du hast da vorne keinerlei Ideen gehabt. Das kommt jetzt dazu. Auch da die gleiche Erzählweise wie bei Chelsea. 140.000 Menschen verpflichtet seit dem Wiederaufstieg. Aber am Ende spielt trotzdem immer Ryan Yates. Also gerade fürs zentrale Mittelfeld. An dem kann man so festmachen, was die alles verpflichtet haben in der Zeit. Brazillianer haben ohne Ende Südamerikaner mit drin. Mongola, also you name it. Und dann spielt am Ende wieder Ryan Yates. Und das ist jetzt zum einen so, dass sie das machen. Ich finde, dass sie relativ clever manchmal vorne draufgehen. Wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann ziehen sie sich wieder zurück. Mir ist das noch zu passiv, deswegen glaube ich, dass ich das nivellieren würde. Aber bis dato funktioniert das einigermaßen. Und wenn sie den Ball selbst haben, dann ist das weiterhin sehr umschaltbasiert. Sie spielen direkt, haben eine relativ gute Pace-Abballeroberung, so Diagonalbälle und so weiter, die Dinge brechen. Dann hast du jemanden drin wie Morgan Gibson White, der ist wahrscheinlich so ein All-Action-Achter, wenn du so willst. Der ist super schwierig zu verteidigen. Das hat in der Zeit lang die ganze Liga gecheckt. Aber dann gehen halt auf der anderen Seite in Ilanga, Ramon Sosa, ganz egal, wie man dann nennen will. Die haben viel Qualität. Dann auch auf den Halbzehner-Position oder Flügelposition. Das ist immer so ein Mischmasch bei denen. Und dann haben sie Chris Wood, der einfach mal wieder– der kann nichts. Es tut mir total leid, wenn ich das so sage. Ich kann nichts. Ich kann einfach nicht Fußball spielen. Aber der erste Kontakt– das ist ein Finisher, das hast du nicht gesehen. Der Kopfball, die Chancenverwertung ist der Wahnsinn. Der zieht leicht nach links, kriegt einen Ball, drin ist er. Teamdienlich, es scheint ein super, super guter Typ zu sein, aber eigentlich kann er nichts. Sobald der einen zweiten Kontakt haben müsste, dann sind seine Mannschaftskollegen am Ende, weil dann ist der Ball weg. Aber sie kriegen ihn halt in solche Möglichkeiten. Das kommt wie immer, wenn so ein Team da oben steht, ist eine gewisse Effizienz erforderlich. Die ist da alleine aufgrund von Chris Wood eben. Nuno Spiritu Santo hat noch nie mehr immer nachgesagt, dass das jemand ist, der eher dann scheint, einen guten Analysten zu haben. In der zweiten Hälfte dann ein paar Dinge umbaut und dann in der zweiten Hälfte dem Gegner ganz gut noch mal zersetzt, also in-game-management, aber eher in halftime-management in dem Fall. Aber auch das funktioniert jetzt von vorneherein etwas besser bei denen und auch das ist, kann man schon sagen, glaube ich, insgesamt eine ziemlich körperliche Mannschaft. Wenngleich, und das habe ich schon gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass die dahin gehören, wo sie sind im Moment, weil mir das wesentlich zu passiv ist insgesamt, weil mir das Pressing nicht gut genug aufgestellt ist und weil, und das ist einfach das, was so ins Auge fällt, weil im Moment jeder Einzelne dermaßen drüber ist, was die Form betrifft. Also es ist unmöglich, dass sie es halten können. Jeder Einzelne ist ein Absoluter, die brennen allesamt. Und das kann so nicht weitergehen. Bis jetzt immer noch das einzige Thema, auch das Liverpool geschlagen hat in der gesamten Spielzeit. Es war genauso eine Masterclass, wie sie es eigentlich immer gemacht haben. Sie stellen sich hinten hin, Robo-Dope, der Gegner soll kommen, kann aber nicht durch. Und irgendwann hast du halt einen Moment und der ist halt dann drin.
Klar.
War wirklich nur einer, der war drin.
Gibt Chris Wood nur einen Kontakt und dann läuft es gut.
Genau.
Ja, sehr schön. Und dann haben wir nämlich auch indirekt. Wir haben ja das letzte Mal mit Jogi hier Ende Oktober über United gesprochen. Und da haben wir die Perspektive von United dann nicht mehr so wirklich noch angeschnitten, weil wir schon so lange gesprochen hatten. Aber warum es United auch mit neuem Trainer wahrscheinlich schwer haben wird, liegt, glaube ich, an allen Teams, über die wir gerade gesprochen haben. Ja, das ist schon eine spannende Situation.
Da sind sie schon auch selber schuld. So ist es nicht. Aber immerhin, ich wäre mir echt viel geschimpft in der letzten Dekade über Man United und auch zurecht. Und auch da werden Menschen links und rechts entlassen, die da seit Jahren Leistung bringen im Verein. Ich meine jetzt noch nicht mal die Mannschaft, sondern im Verein. Aber, und das habe ich mir nochmal sagen lassen, mit sehr viel mehr Klasse. Also es wird nicht einfach wahllos ausgedünnt, du weg, du weg, du weg, du weg, sondern es wird geguckt. Wie geht es den Familiär? Kann es das irgendwie, irgendwas, können wir den vielleicht irgendwo anders noch einen Job geben? Es ist ein insgesamt sehr langsamer Verein, was auch jetzt so die Kulturveränderung betrifft, was glaube ich dann positiv ist. Trotzdem natürlich ist es, wie es ist. Ineos ist da und die wollen Erfolg haben und zwar auch einigermaßen schnell Erfolg haben, aber es ist nicht haruk. Also, man könnte das auch wie bei Chelsea machen und sagen, so, du bist jetzt hier 20 Jahre Kidman. Ja, whatever, ciao. Das macht man halt so nicht. Und nicht nur deshalb, aber auch deshalb. Ich habe das Gefühl, Ineos, also ich habe mir ein bisschen was erzählen lassen aus dem Trainerfindungsprozess. Scheint ein sehr, sehr, sehr langfristiger gewesen zu sein. Sehr, sehr viele Background-Checks, also auch da viel im Datenbereich, viel aber auch grundsätzlich, was die Machbarkeit betrifft. Also gar nicht bei Guardiola angefragt oder so wie halt Bayern. Jeden einzelnen Trainer, der eine UEFA-POL-Lizenz hat, der fragt man mal vorsichtig an mit so einem Brief oder was Böse formuliert. Sondern schon nach Machbarkeit und auch wahnsinnig viel privater Background-Check. Also im Sinne von ist die Persönlichkeit für uns ausreichend, damit da nicht wieder jemand kommt, dem es einfach über den Kopf wächst. Und ich habe insgesamt so das Gefühl, dass INEOS einen ganz guten Plan hat. Haben auf allen erdenklichen Positionen Leute installiert. Also endlich mal so was wie einen Director of Sports, einen technischen Direktor, beides sogar. Hatten sie ja ewig nicht. Einfach eine fußballerische Leitlinie. Geschweige denn den Plan, das ist da. Deswegen auf dem Weg in die richtige Richtung. Aber ja, das ist ja das Bittere. Während United jetzt zum nächsten Mal neu aufbaut, haben sich halt in der Zwischenzeit schon wieder 3, 4, 5 Teams komplett neu erfunden und sind schon wieder vorbeigezogen. Das ist das Gestaunliche.
Aber wirklich.
Lange Antwort, sorry.
Du, alles gut. Jetzt haben wir noch spontan über United gesprochen. Ist doch schön. Uli, ich danke dir sehr, sehr herzlich für deine Zeit. Das hat wie immer große Freude gemacht.
Danke dir.
Und ich danke natürlich auch nochmal unseren Gästen von vor Jahren, Fabian Pakulat, Christian Bernhardt und Alexi Menüsch. Und zuletzt möchte ich natürlich auch euch danken, lieben Hörern und Hörern. Denn ihr ermöglicht Sendungen wie diese hier. Der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werber und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Und unter anderem haben das getan Grumbas, Dumbas, Knupsch, der Seebe, Killer, FFM, Casper und Samira. Sie alle sind auf rasenfunk.de gegangen und haben dann auf den Unterstützen-Button geklickt. Den findet ihr sehr einfach. Und da erfahrt ihr auch, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Geht eigentlich auf allen gängigen Wegen. Jeder Betrag hilft. Herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Herzlichen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt gesund und uns gewogen. Und dann hören wir uns bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao! Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!